hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ihr seht schon mein bauch respekt
die kleine ella ist da und zwar kam die
kleine am 24 oktober auf die welt
und wenn wir auf instagram falls und auf
facebook folgt da weiß es auch schon
denn dort habe ich auch schon zwei drei
sachen gepostet und die geburt verkündet
ja und heute möchte ich jetzt in diesem
video einfach so ein bisschen was über
die geburt erzählen ihr habt ganz viele
fragen gestellt auf instagram und auch
auf facebook und ich möchte euch jetzt
einfach so ein bisserl ja einfach
erzählen wie es halt losging und wie es
uns jetzt im moment geht also am 23
oktober also der abend bevor vater
geburt da waren wir noch ganz gemütlich
zu hause musste mich und wir hatten noch
freunde eingeladen unsere freundin
sabrina mit ihrem mann und die ist
nämlich auch gerade schwanger und wir
haben eigentlich immer gedacht okay bei
mir dauert jetzt doch ein bisschen
länger
und vielleicht schaffen wir es wirklich
gleichzeitig krankenhaus zu sein hat es
im endeffekt doch nicht geklappt aber an
dem abend saßen dann noch ganz gemütlich
zusammen und haben bisschen was gegessen
bisschen was süßes was eigentlich auch
sehr untypisch für mich ein letztes jahr
schon merken müssen
ich bin eigentlich nicht so die
naschkatze die dann den ganzen tisch
voller süßigkeiten hat und sich da
irgendwie vollstopft aber irgendwie an
dem abend keine ahnung hatte ich so ein
hunger auf süßes und hatte auch den
ganzen abend schon rückenschmerzen und
habe mich auch immer wieder beklagt über
die rückenschmerzen
aber ich habe es halt wirklich ernst
genommen weil wir hatten ja schon zwei
wochen vorher mal ein fehlalarm wo wir
dann im krankenhaus war und zwar einfach
nichts dann habe ich gedacht komm jetzt
macht mal die pferde schon borat mal nix
gehe einfach irgendwann schlafen und ja
dann zimmer irgendwann um 12 oder mainz
glaube ich ins bett gegangen also
ziemlich spät und ich bin nacht in der
nacht richtig oft aufgewacht ich habe
eigentlich die ganze gedacht ich mach
auch weil der mord hat so leicht aber
ich gucke nicht so stecken bleiben will
und dann habe ich die ganze zeit muratow
schneide ich so schnell wie ich ständig
auf die toilette und habe gar nicht
gemerkt dass ich im schlaf hat
rückenschmerzen hatte umgehen hatte
und irgendwann habe ich dann gedacht
okay ich hab vor bauchschmerzen aber ich
lege mich mal hin wenn es schlimmer wird
mache ich dann schon irgendwann
und morgens um sex war dann das letzte
mal dass ich aufgewacht bin und dann
habe ich halt gemerkt dass die
fruchtblase geplatzt war
und hab dann auch gleich der murat
aufgeweckt und sagt okay morath jetzt
geht es wirklich los und ich hab gedacht
ich habe viel geschwitzt alles war so
nass stimmt das ist müsst ihr euch so
vorstellen wenn der wenn das baby im
bauch ganz normal liegt das heißt mit
kopf nach unten
dann sitzt ja das kurz vor der geburt
ziemlich weit im becken und man hat halt
unter dem kopf ein bisschen fruchtwasser
noch und wenn man dann halt ein
blasensprung hat dann kommt halt nur so
ein bisschen fruchtwasser und der rest
bleibt dann halt im bauch weil der kopf
daneben den ausgang versperrt
dazu wenn ihr euch das dazu vorstellen
können also nicht so wie im fernsehen
das dann irgendwie da macht es klatsch
und alles ist voller wasser das ist
wirklich eigentlich nur wenn's kind
falsch rum liegt kann man diese
verstehen ja plötzlich machen finden
genau da hat ja den blasensprung und
hatte dann auch richtig heftig gewesen
also wen es haben ja auch wieder gefragt
wie fühlen sich wehen an
das ist halt so von schmerz im bauch im
rücken ist zieht die beine rund als
zumindest bei mir so sieht halt die
beine runter und eigentlich bisschen
undefinierbar und man weiß nicht
wirklich wo her und es tut halt weh
deswegen w
genau deswegen will man ja nicht dass es
deswegen heißt wie ja ich denke es weh
tut warum sonst kommt auch wehtun von
wem man weiß es nicht
ja auf jeden fall haben uns dann gleich
ins auto gesetzt in der nacht war es
auch so zufälligerweise hatte lisa mir
bei meiner mama geschlafen bei der oma
und wir mussten sie dann deswegen nennt
noch wegfahren und sie nachher direkt
ins krankenhaus gefahren und ich hab
echt gesagt okay also ich glaube
innerhalb der nächsten zwei stunden
kommt sie bestimmt weil halt wirklich
hat das so einen druck im bauch also so
richtig so ein druck nach unten und hab
dann gedacht okay zum glück fahren jetzt
auch morgens in der früh wo halt noch
kein verkehr ist und ja ja ja der firma
hat im krankenhaus angekommen
angemeldet waren wir schon weil wir
schon mal da waren zum fehlalarm
und dann wurde ich eben anders cd gerät
angeschlossen das ist das gerät wo man
eben die wm ist und die venen schreibt
und auch die herztöne vom kind muss
damit man eben immer weiß vor der geburt
geht es dem kind gut und kann man eine
normale geburt haben oder muss man eben
irgendwie nach hilfen
reiten oder so ja das war dann so kurz
vor 7 und dann hat's halt gedauert
werden halt gewartet irgendwann habe ich
was kleines gefrühstückt hat hunger
hatte und dann habe ich dann immer mal
wieder das ct gerät dran bekommen hab
mich hingelegt konnte noch bisschen
schlafen und es hat sich eigentlich so
ein bisschen gezogen
gegen 15 uhr kanadier glaub ich glaube
um 15 uhr genau was an so dann kam die
nati an meine beste freundin meine mama
weiß amira und ich wollte einfach mal
jemanden dabei haben und hab dann eben
die nadja noch gerufen die dann auch
gleich kam
und dann bin ich irgendwann in den
kreißsaal zur ging es weiter und 15
jahre stimmt nadja kamer wir sind dann
zusammen im kreis haben da hab ich mir
dann gewünscht dass ich eine
wassergeburt habe das heißt ich konnten
die badewanne hätte sich hat auch
ziemlich entspannend und auch wen
fördernd gut bei den einen dann mehr weh
also die wie bei den anderen schweizern
er ab bei mir war es dann eher so dass
es kurz etwas abgeschwächt war und dann
wurde eben doch wieder stärker und die
zeit finden also die diese venen faser
dann die wir heißen die phase als dieser
erster geburts phase also nicht die
ausschreibungsphase sondern da wo sich
dann eben der muttermund öffnet war auch
eine ziemlich schöne zeit weil ich
konnte mich aminata unterhalte und murat
und mit der hebamme es war lustig und es
richtig das war wie sollen kaffeeklatsch
erwartet also ich sags halt eine warte
warte alle anderen außen rum und dann
kam halt ab und zu eine wti habe
strandweg geatmet und da habe ich mich
dann weiter unterhalte mit den beiden
aber du hast ja da waren sie mal dass du
aus einem anderen zimmer habe ich über
schreie gehört und er hat ja da war
da waren so heftige schreie und der
morath hat gefragt
exotisch berufen soll die hebamme hat
sich nicht mehr gekriegt
das ist schon heftig wenn man dann
selber so kurz vor der geburt steht und
an andere frauen schreien hört wobei hat
mir net wirklich angst das so gemacht
habe mich darauf gefreut und habe
eigentlich nur darauf gewartet bis sie
endlich kommt
echt nicht mehr erwarten können außer
wirklich so eine schöne runde und
irgendwann wurden halt die weniger
heftiger woran hat sich übrigens
zwischendurch in essen bestellen aus der
mensa also aus bistro küche darf aus dem
netz geschmeckt habe noch nie so
schlecht ist mein leben der ganze kreis
hat nach dem essen gestimmt und so
schlecht habe ich echt wegen dem essen
übergeben
ich habe dann eine gabel probiert das
lasso furchtbar
und dann hat er sich einen döner stellt
den hat er dann draußen geläuf forum
kreis gibt den habe ich gebrochen bis in
den kreis alles wasser furchtbar nach
das video und knoblauch und kräuter
schon mal notfall würde und deswegen war
halt auch die nazi attacke weil so murat
muss sich als ersthelfer pflege und dann
machen die nadja bei mir naja gottes
essen
ich glaube es war die schlimmste
erfahrung während der geburt na ja auf
jeden fall irgendwann hatte ich halt so
stark gewesen dass er hat wirklich
richtig wehgetan haben und die ging dann
auch mehrere minuten
und da musste ich auch kurz aus der
wanne raus weil das war dann so 16 uhr
30 oder so irgendwie weil man die
herztöne hat nicht mehr messen konnte
unter wasser und dann musste ich eben
raus dass wir fünf minuten am stück eben
zum ctg schreiben konnten
und dann war ich gar keine zeit mehr um
in die wanne zurückzugeben weil da hatte
ich schon meine presswehen und hab dann
einfach wie man eben auf diesen auf
diese liege und habe dann da halt die
kleine ella gekriegt ich froh dass
notiert aber und ich habe bis dahin
ich hab das auch vorher schon da hebt
aber gesagt dass ich halt keine pda
möchte und keine schmerzmittel möchte
weil ich halt die ela so natürlich wie
möglich bekommen möchte und ich hatte
auch bei der samira damals eine
einleitung und hatte da hat künstlich
erwähnen und da muss ja sagen die waren
halt im vergleich dazu fiel viel
heftiger und viel schlimmer und ich habe
die damals hat auch so ausgehalten und
habe gedacht kommt das ist jetzt auch
schmerzen die gehen ein paar stunden
halt vorbei und probiere es halt einfach
ohne ich weiß noch es gab einen moment
da habe ich kurz bereut weil dann echte
schmerzen so schlimm war aber am ende
fand ich dann doch wieder schön weil
weil du spürst halt alles und du kannst
auch richtig mit pressen und du immer so
yamada einfach das gefühl dafür und
beinahe pda ist das oder bekommt er
vieles daneben
nicht mehr mit und oftmals ist auch so
dass frauen dann nicht mehr erpressen
können weil es halt nicht spüren und
dann aber zum beispiel die hebamme das
kind raus drücken und verlogen und ja
auf jeden fall hatte ich halt keine und
es war ganz gut und ich muss sagen die
geburt an sich also von morgens um sex
hat sie angefangen blasensprung mit den
venen und so weiter und die diese
ausschreibungsphase also die press phase
ich weiß hat die ausschreibungs
vorsichtig so exotisch ich weiß es ging
vielleicht nur stunde bis zum schluss
ger ich weiß ich weiß
gefühl gehabt familienfreundliches hals
bis 17 uhr 28 da war sie dann da auf der
welt und ich muss euch sagen das
schönste moment weiß seiner geburt ist
eigentlich wenn die hebamme dann
irgendwie sagt das köpfchen star und hat
sie zum beispiel gesagt es hat ganz
dunkle schwarze haare und es stand zu
motivieren für dich als mama und dann
wird es einfach fertig bringen und
einfach alles hinter sich bringen und ja
ich glaube also das schönste moment für
mich war als das köpfchen da war du
weißt dass ich gleich geschafft und dann
ist sie da ich konnte dann noch nicht
direkt auf den arm nehmen weil die
nabelschnur hall zu kurz war
die nabelschnur durfte dann die nach
durchtrennen
weil der morath der nicht wissen kann
kein blut sehen und er kann es halt ich
habe das datum für den kindergeld
eintrag habe ich bis vor beitragen ob
ich gleich gestellt ja und das ist
wirklich schön
ich habe gedacht es kommt irgendwo auch
so ein blöder spruch dass ich jetzt
nicht so emotional wird
und dann ist das so dann haben sie die
nabelschnur durchtrennt und dann konnte
ich halt die kleine ella auf meinen
schoß nehmen und es kommt ja dann noch
eine nachgeburt die plazenta also der
mutterkuchen das wasser eben das kind
die ganzen monate lang versorgt und das
ist halt so das sieht aus wie so ein
stück leber ich ja wie so ein großes
stück leber und
bei vielen ist es brauch dass man die
plazenta mit nach hause nimmt und die
dann eingelebt und zwar ein baum darauf
pflanzt ja ich habe schon von vornherein
gesagt dass ich das nicht machen möchte
und dass man die entsorgen kann
beziehungsweise einfach zu weiteren
zwecken irgendwie verbinden kann
und dann fragt die hebamme uns ob wir
sie halt mitnehmen möchten und dem motto
courtney hat ja wohl die sämige uns
angucken und hab ich das nämlich hatte
bei dass amira schon gesehen und ich
brauchte ihn noch einmal sehen und der
murat ich sag ja da kann kein blut sehen
dreht sich weg guckt voll auf die
plazenta die da irgendwie in so einem
waschbecken oder so liegt trete ich
wieder weg da ich auch alles zurück und
blut also dem ging es dann ganz kurz
ganz schlecht aber sicherlich schlimm
ist also das gehört halt mit dazu zu
einer geburt aber was ich halt richtig
richtig eklig fand ich war ich
vielleicht keinen persönlich angreifen
der vielleicht aus der kultur kommt aber
es soll halt länder geben in denen man
die plazenta mit nach hause nimmt und
dann alles und dann halt ein rezept
damit kocht also so eine plazenta
lasagne oder so wieder der geburt als
verlässlich skandinavischen ländern
anscheinend ja ich kann mir das gar
nicht vorstellen sie sich für mich sehr
dass islamischen das wird das wird auch
die ikea möbel dann wieso ich sagen naja
vertiefen wir das jetzt weiter fest
kennt ja jemand den brauchen kann was
dazu schreiben
auf jeden fall besser links für mich ja
ich bin froh wenn es einfach weg ich aus
dem körper lassen
naja dann war es so dann hat man halt so
eine gewisse zeit für sich und für das
baby ich hab dann die ella kurz dem
orange gegeben glaubt ordination leuten
army dorsten nicht genommen milliwatt
noch zu zerbrechlich genau die nati hat
sie dann genommen dann wird sie gewogen
und gemessen und so weiter man hat nach
der geburt und halt auch noch nachwehen
das ist ganz normal weil sich die
gebärmutter er dann in die gebärmutter
kinder zum schluss bisher hoch und die
muss ich ja dann erst mal wieder runter
zusammenziehen und hat man eben auch
nachwehen und je mehr kinder man hat
umso mehr nach wien hat man halt auch
und deswegen waren sie diesmal bei mir
ein bisschen heftiger aber es gibt auch
frauen die empfinden die nicht heftig
und das ist halt immer ganz individuell
ja auf jeden fall waren wir dann
ungefähr bestimmt noch so zwei stunden
im kreis dann
sind meine eltern auch gekommen mit der
samira und bei der samira wasser dem
ring hat vorher ein foto geschickt ja
aber es war schon einzig habt ihr noch
ein leute für apple ja ja ja genau
während ich in der wanne sitzung die
wehen habe und die weg atme hat
demokratia fotos fasching und zwar mit
von mir aber er hat dann ein bild von
dem baby mit dem schnauzer und so ganz
vielen haaren an die samira geschickt
also an meine mutter und jetzt dass
amira gezeigt und hat man gesagt das
baby ist da und dann macht die samir
eine sprachaufzeichnung und sagt nein
nein verfahre ich will das baby nicht
ich möchte dass das baby kein
schnurrbart hat und hat sich dann stahl
geschwister vorstelle ich stehe da und
hab' krieg gerade ein kind im monat
macht sauer
naja finnwaa hat er dann ein richtiges
foto von der iller geschickt und die
samira hat sich dahinter und richtig
gefreut und hat richtig geschrien vor
lauter freude haben kuchen gebacken für
uns noch mittags mit meiner mama und
dann sind sie halt abends gekommen und
ich wollte eigentlich dass die ich
gerade in meinem arm ist wenn die samira
kommt aber irgendwie haben wir das nicht
gut abgesprochen
aber es war auch gar kein problem weil
die kam dann gleich zu uns ins fett und
hat sich mit dazu gelegt und hat gleich
mit ihr gekuschelt und das war total
also es war richtig schön so total
emotional auch und der die ihre kleine
schwester gleich ins herz geschlossen
und war total stolz aufsehen hat gleich
erzählt guck mal das ist meine kleine
schwester und zwar recht schön sind
arbeit gewöhnt meine lieben papa da hat
er noch den namen gegeben also bei uns
ist so dass man halt wir haben keine
taufe oder so und dann habe ich ja mein
papa gegeben und dann hat er so ein
gebet gesprochen und hat ihr den namen
halt genau und das hat er dann gemacht
das gibt was er noch gebracht hat sagt
da einfach meine kindheit meine kindheit
ist ella da irgendwie da war ganz
emotional ich weiß auch nicht wieso ich
mal meine schwester heißt meine
schwiegermama ist schwester wieso der
ihm ein kind abkaufen wollten
naja war ich kurz schockiert auch er hat
dann korrigiert ich glaube für ihn geht
jetzt aber einschnitte als zweitname
oder aber ob abrufe zweitname wir haben
nur ella genannt also ohne zweitnamen
weil weil wir sie nicht auf eine
waldorfschule schicken deswegen
entwicklung ein name ja als nur ein name
und vom sternzeichen her ist jetzt auch
in skorpion wie die sanierer
das kann lustig werden in der pubertät
meine zwei schwestern sind skorpione ich
weiß wovon ich spreche ja dann waren wir
wurden wir halt in unser zimmer
gebrachte abends noch um neun oder so
und wer hat als ich wir hatten ein
familienzimmer
das heißt der mossad war dann eben mit
bei mir das größte extra kosten extra
bezahlen und es kann aber jeder kann
sich jeder buch und wenn es kranken
haushalt hergibt also bei uns war das
halt im krankenhaus so dass man da
einzel einbett zimmer buchen konnte man
konnte familienzimmer buch und so weiter
aber muss es halt immer extra ich glaube
wir haben glaube ich glaube müsse es 150
euro pro nacht bezahlt es ist nicht
wenig aber mir war es halt wichtig dass
der mossad dabei ist weil ja bei samira
war ich in einem doppelzimmer mit jemand
anderem das war okay aber ihr wisst das
ist dann immer so da hat man keine
privatsphäre dann große liebe deine
pläne deine person die mit ihrem zimmer
warten die hat mir leid getan haben dass
das reisen weil sie hatte halt kaum
besucht und bei mir war halt immer total
viel besuch da und es hat mich total
blöd für sie dann also bei ihr kann man
immer ihr mann und ihre mama oder so und
bei mir kann man dann noch mein bruder
und
was halt normal ist dass meine ganzen
geschwister kommen und das markante
deswegen maximal diesmal ein
einzelzimmer und daneben noch eine
morath dazu die samira kammer hat
tagsüber mit meinen eltern und ich habe
auch wieder mit denen nach hause weil
ich muss mich ja nachts um dna kümmern
und kann mich ja damit noch um die
familie kümmern und die haben über essen
gebracht und die haben uns essen
gebracht weil das essen im krankenhaus
war echt furchtbar auch das war ganz
schön angefressen wobei das war ja lange
gesprochen
ja und jagt sie haben natürlich nur ein
bestimmtes budget kochen für ein menü
und das wäre besser gewesen in
krankenhäusern sparen sie oft und am
essen zum beispiel ganz extrem
man sagt ja nicht es ist widerlich essen
schmecken hat den respekt vor dem essen
also einmal habe ich gegessen es war
okay davon hat ab gekochte kartoffel
aber könnte ich es falsch machen haben
dass es mal wirklich ach gott ach das
frühstück also april will das budget
einfach nicht ich kann eigentlich immer
nur marmelade brot frühstücke und ganz
ehrlich als stillende mama ist das hat
nicht gerade das gesündeste und für die
verdauung ist auch nicht wirklich gut
von daher na ja man hat mich mal
irgendwie gemüsegarten gemüse starkes
wahnsinn also haben oder starker
exotisch nicht mehr ballaststoffe die du
zu dir nehmen kann ich das irgendwie
seine verdauung wieder in schwung kommt
oder so weil nach der geburt hat mir
plötzlich wieder so viel platz im bauch
und du musst ja was essen was eben seine
verdauung in schwung hält aber das war
halt leider auch nicht deswegen hat der
[ __ ] ab und zu uns geholt um meine
eltern haben mir immer was gebracht und
das war dann okay wir waren insgesamt
vier nächte im krankenhaus und zwar kam
die ela abends auf die welt und dann
muss man eben die u2 also diese
untersuchung also die u1 wird direkt im
kreis noch gemacht dass sich dieses
liegen usw und die u2 wird dann eben
nach 48 stunden gemacht und da haben
dann eben noch so den dritten tag
abwarten müssen bis es eben gemacht
wurde und dann durften wir endlich nach
hause gehen und haben dann auch
unterwegs gleich die samira abgeholt
dann sind wir kurz was essen gegangen
weil wir so hunger hatten und dann soll
endlich auf uns nach hause gekommen und
das war richtig schön also da konnte man
dann erstmal
ankommen dann aber mit der lektion
einfach mal wachsen einfach mal ankommen
und mein fürs baby ist es ja dann
wir kommen ja nach hause aber das baby
ist eine neue umgebung also allein schon
aus dem bauch raus im krankenhaus war
die neue umgebung und dann nach hause
kommen ist die neue umgebung und dann
muss man einfach mal ankommen
und ich glaube an dem abends in meine
eltern noch gekommen oder ja das braucht
man auch ja man muss erstmal selber
ankommen ja und für uns ging dann
einfach der alltag normal weiter die
samira durfte am nächsten tag wieder in
kindergarten also durfte er die ganze
zeit aber an dem tag hatte moratti dann
eben wieder gefragten nicht meine eltern
und für uns waren die ersten tage
ziemlich anstrengend weil die ja noch
tag und nacht so ein bisschen
verwechselt hat weil in meinem bauch war
sie immer nachts aktiv und das war's
halt dann auch nach der geburt wird auch
nach der geburt erst mal gar nicht
geschlafen und hat einfach nur geguckt
und ich konnte nicht schlafen die erste
nacht aber jetzt so langsam stellt sich
zum und sie merkt okay jetzt einen
betrag jetzt haben wir nacht und ich
gucke jetzt halt auch dass ich nachts
immer wenig mit ihr sprechen und sie
weniger winkler als tagsüber zum
beispiel das waren so tipps die mit die
hebamme gegeben hat und apropos hebamme
es ist auch so nach der geburtstags wenn
ihr ebene hebamme habt das was ich euch
wirklich sehr empfehlen die kommt ja
dann auch jeden tag zu euch nach hause
und kontrolliert erstmalig auch den
bauch die gebärmutter und kontrolliert
dann eben auch euer baby und das finde
ich immer so ganz beruhigend zu wissen
dass man sie ihren daneben auch sieht
okay das baby nimmt zu es trinkt genug
der bauchnabel wird kontrolliert er las
bauchnabel ich ist zum beispiel schon
abgefallen
das heißt wir durften sie jetzt auch
schon baden das haben wir auch zusammen
gemacht jetzt ist so ich glaube neun
tage weiß die eller alt jetzt kommen die
hebamme erst nächste woche wieder und
dann guckt man einfach wie oft sie eben
noch kommt und dass sich das eben alles
normalisiert also man hat dann
irgendwann selber zu sein alltag und
bekommt dann eben hoffentlich alles hin
ja und aktuell geht es uns ganz gut ein
echtes inhalt noch anstrengend
weiter orad krieg studie was mit ich
glaube hier im kinderzimmer zu sanieren
zimmer gezogen samira ich bei mir
heute nacht war zum beispiel zwischen 3
50 und 5 uhr alle drei mädels bach also
die elfer war heute halt in der gegend
rum geguckt hat die mama wache und die
samira butter auch machen hat sie ihr
wissen was vorgesungen hat sie sehr
massiert bisserl gestreichelt und
geküsst dann ich die ella irgendwann
eingeschlafen
das haben wir auch nicht konnte danach
wieder schlafen aber irgendwie weiter
bewacht stand auf und eigentlich
gestimmt todmüde und würde gern weiter
schlafen aber sie stand nicht schlimm
weil sich das ist keine wesen anguckt
und an lächelt und ja die sanierer nimmt
es auch ganz locker als ich finde es
echt schön teuer muss man echt sagen
unser alltag sieht jetzt so aus also
morgens stehen wir ganz normal auf um
halb 7 7
damit die samira fertig gemacht bzw
macht sich auch alleine fertig sie schon
groß und wenn die ela schon wache ist
dann wird die hand gespielt dann hat
sich so kurz ihre wachphase dann kann es
am meer nämlich kurz mit ihr kuscheln
der morath fährt dann die samira zum
kindergarten und dann habe ich einfach
zeit für mich dann gehe ich eben duschen
usw
und jetzt ist hat gerade noch schön weil
ich jetzt noch so ein paar tagen im
monat ab nächster woche geht er leiter
wieder zur arbeit
dann ist leider vorbei dann muss ich
halt gucken dass ich die samira zum
kindergarten fahren
das heißt ich muss mich dann vorher
fertig machen und dann samira und
daneben los aber sich auch kein problem
im moment dreht sich halt zwar viel ist
schon um die l ab und ist jetzt nicht so
dass unser kompletter alltag jetzt
irgendwie umstrukturiert wurde weil ja
ich meine sie brauchen nicht viel sie
muss eigentlich nur gestellt und
gewickelt werden und dann schläft sehr
wieder
ich denke in so ein paar wochen und
monaten ändert sich das dann auch da hat
sie ihre längeren wachphasen wieder mehr
aufmerksamkeit will dass man mit ihr
spielt aber ich denke es spielt sich
dann auch ganz gut ein und dürften
eigentlich kein problem sein
hoffe ich zumindest und ja dann wurde
ich noch gefragt wie sieht's mit einem
gewicht aus also ich wollte mich
eigentlich direkt nach der geburt wiegen
aber da gibt es auch keine wage ich hab
es dann auch ehrlich gesagt vergessen
und ich habe mich dann ich glaub sechs
tage nach geburt mal gewogen
da hatte ich noch so zehn kilo drauf
jetzt habe ich mich vor gestand bei
meiner mama
bogen und hatte noch so etwa acht kilo
drauf also man sieht so es geht langsam
weg vor allem auch durch stillen dafür
braucht man halt sehr viele kalorien
man muss aber auch trotzdem noch
weiterhin gesund und genug essen also
ihr könnt jetzt nicht während der
stillzeit einfach sagen okay ich mache
keine diät weil das baby braucht auch
die nährstoffe und die muttermilch muss
ja auch eine gute qualität haben heißt
jetzt nicht dass ihr euch überfressen
sollt ihr müsst einfach ganz normal
essen gesund essen ausgewogen essen viel
obst und gemüse und das mache ich eben
ich muss im moment noch eisenreich essen
weil ich grad noch sowie den eisenmangel
habt aber das ist kein problem es ist
jetzt nicht so dass ich irgendwelche
präparate nehmen muss aber ich kann es
einfach durch die ernährung ein bisschen
ausgleichen
ja da noch die frage hat murat während
der geburt geweint ja er hat wieder
geweint habe ich nicht verstehe
es war das war das wasser von dem bade
badewasser wassergeburt draußen ja aber
sicher auch aus emotionales und was sehr
schön ist und was einen eben auch sehr
berührt dann was eigentlich glaube ich
das gas so zur geburt liebe drehen
wieder
naja ich dreh seit dieser woche wieder
bereit mich auf weihnachts- rezepte und
winter rezepte vor
ich glaube war für manche so ein
bisschen durcheinander weil ja jetzt im
moment noch videos kamen mit
schwangerschaftsbauch und war immer so
her ist die ja schon da ist ja noch
nicht da ich habe ein paar vorproduziert
damit ich eben jetzt so ein paar tage
für mich habe und jetzt wieder ganz
normal einsteigen kann und deswegen
produzieren wir seit dieser woche wieder
und nächste woche kommt news genau
nächste woche kommen dann auch wieder
videos was ich übrigens in der hand
halte ist unser buch es ist noch nicht
ganz fertig ist nämlich im druck und das
gibt es ab ende november
und ich freue mich schon richtig drauf
also das ist jetzt so die erste ausgabe
mal gewesen und der erscheinungstermin
ja ende november
das heißt ganz bald könnt ihr sie schon
auch begriffe
ja ich mache da extra noch mal ein video
dazu und die samira ist auch ganz stolz
weil wir da auf dem cover mit drauf ist
und das ist sie und es ist ziemlich dick
das stimmt aber ich schreibe ich das
dann noch mal extra und erzählt euch was
dazu und zeigt euch so ein paar seiten
auf jeden fall ja morath ich glaube ja
warum sie nicht da ist ach so ja die
erlebst radja die ist eine abstellkammer
hht schläft hier neben ja genau ich
wollte ja auch gefragt sagte die airline
in videos ich denke ich mache da auch
mal so ein extra video dazu wie ich zu
dem ganzen schnee also ich hab euch ja
auch schon mal erzählt dass zum beispiel
samira ich habe jetzt seit dreieinhalb
jahren meinen youtube kanal und
irgendwann kam die samira dazu ich habe
am anfang hat immer versucht raus zu
halten weil ich an edward dass sie mit
in den videos mit dabei ist und aber
irgendwann ging es halt nicht mehr weil
irgendwann läuft sie halt und spricht
und kommt dann halt ständig in die küche
und wenn ich da etwas macht dann macht
sie halt mit dann hat sie sich praktisch
in meine videos mit reingedrängt
sozusagen und ich möchte einfach die im
moment noch nicht so in die
öffentlichkeit drängen sage ich jetzt
mal und wird da einfach abwarten bis sie
das von alleine macht in den videos das
heißt bis sie dann auch rein schneit und
sagt mama jetzt gehe ich jetzt jetzt
auch ein bisschen mit
aber ich habe zum beispiel auf instagram
und auf facebook auch schon 23 bilder
gezeigt ich meine babys ist ja auch so
die verändert sich auch wirklich jeden
tag also wenn ich jetzt so die bilder
anschaut von ella bei der geburt elan
nach drei tagen eher nach einer woche
das sieht diese halt immer komplett
anders aus die verändern sich so schnell
also echt wahnsinn
deswegen muss man sich immer schön
festhalten das vergisst man auch so
schnell wie klein die dann noch waren
und alles ja wir sehen war sowie beim
man bei der hochzeit war richtig toll
aus oder geht es ganz plötzlich immer
dicke decke fallen die haare heraus und
so genau so muss man das sehen
so ist mein baby geht auch ziemlich
schnell klar wenn du dich vor sieben
jahre siehst ja komm papa man muss ja
nicht gehen lassen
ja auf jeden fall war das ist so eine
kleine übersicht über die geburt über
uns uns geht es gut und wir versuchen
unseren normalen alltag wieder
hinzubekommen bzw haben ihnen eigentlich
schon wieder
und ja jetzt gehen wir auch gleich die
sanierer abholen gehen auch noch eine
runde spazieren und morgen morgen gibt
es wieder eine leckere einen leckeren
kuchen ein klassiker und zwar einen
vereinfachten klassiker es gibt nämlich
eine falsche linzertorte der
mittlerweile ziemlich gequält machen
jetzt machen wir schluss weil jetzt soll
es wieder viel zu lang
ok also was vergessen was komplikation
übrigen gewähren geburtstag gottheil das
würde ich auch gefragt gab es
komplikationen während der geburt sich
tut mir leid darf ich jetzt kurz was
machen bitte ich liebe es ich sie es bei
rtl immer wenn es immer so traurig ist
geschichten gibt da hab ich das machen
was dann also die stelle die frage gab
es komplikationen während der geburt
frankreich gab es komplikationen während
der geburt jetzt
und jetzt beantwortet die frage
beantworte ich nicht nein es gab keine
komplikationen wir haben da was ich so
früh ich sagen so ein bisschen trauen
nein es gab keine gruppen bei murat bild
wieder normal und es gab keine
komplikationen super papa gesagt